hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skin care nerd
and owner of freshly bleached hair
i've had a lot of questions
about how i maintain my hair
and i did a video about my hair routine
back in january but a few things have
changed since then mostly i've gotten even
more lazy so i thought i'd film an update
if you like finding out more about
the science behind beauty products
click the like the subscribe and click the
nerdification bell so you don't miss any videos
so i went to the same salon as last
time which is ultrafade by rich
and this time i had a different hairdresser and i
think she went a little bit less hard on my hair
so it's a little bit less white than last time but
it's still light enough that i can get this color
i think the biggest difference from last time
is that i started using amodimethicone products
from the first wash my hair's a lot more
manageable than last time it's a lot less
damaged i don't think i've seen a single split
end even though last time there were tons
i do think amodimethicone was the biggest
game changer for me even more than olaplex
it's a silicone that doesn't weigh down your hair
quite as much as most of the common silicones
or at least with my hair i've had a lot of people
tell me that it worked really well for them too
amodimethicone has a positive charge
like charges repel and so you can't
get too much amodimethicone in your hair
once it's in there another amodimethicone
molecule can't get that close to it and
so you don't end up with too much buildup
amodimethicone also crosslinks and forms a film
and so that can last through several washes
that means that the smooth feeling that you
get after you wash your hair and conditioner
that will last for a bit longer and so having this
smooth feel means that when you brush it when you
tie it up when you do whatever with your hair it's
a lot smoother it doesn't snag on things and it
doesn't snag on itself and so that prevents future
damage so the exact products i've been using with
amodimethicone have changed i've been using
the toni and guy volume addiction conditioner
i was using this last time as well the problem
with this is that there are a bunch of different
versions and not all of them have amodimethicone
really high up on the ingredients list so
usually i look at that as an indication that
there's a bit more in it i get this from the
supermarket and it goes on half price all the
time so every time i go grocery shopping i
wander through the shampoo aisle and check and
stock up if it's at eight dollars i've also been
trying this garnier treatment it is the sleek and
shine leave-in conditioning cream i got this from
iherb i don't know if it's actually available
in australia it's a leave-in treatment so if my
hair's been feeling a bit rough after i wash it
i'll add a bit of this on the ends sometimes i'll
mix it with olaplex 3 or 6 to get that extra bond
repair as well so because amodimethicone has been
working so well for me i've been able to wash my
hair more frequently so i wash it every second day
which is my preferred amount i have a pretty oily
scalp so i've been using a lot less dry shampoo
i haven't had a lot of success with dry shampoo
because a lot of them tend to irritate my scalp
so it's really nice that i get to avoid that now
but it does mean that i do have to re-dye my hair
a bit more often by re-dyeing what i mean is i
use shampoos and conditioners that deposit color
and my hair isn't like a really bright color
so it doesn't need that much dye so my favorite
that i was using last time as well is the fudge
professional clean blonde violet turning shampoo
with a lot of the other purple shampoos i've been
trying i found that they tend to dry out my hair
and dry out my scalp my hair can't handle any more
drying so this is really good i've also been using
a new brand called kyn k y n unfortunately they
are a clean brand and i think you all know my
feelings about clean brands but they do have
a rose gold shampoo and i haven't really found
other brands that do pink shampoos let me know
if you know of any i am trying to go for like
a pinkish purple color right now it's probably a
bit too purple and silvery gray which is great but
not quite the color i'm aiming for yeah so i've
been alternating between pink and purple colors
to try to keep it within the color i want if it's
a bit too purple i use the pink if it's a bit too
pink i use the purple the main reason why i've
been going for pinkish this time even though i
love this silvery purple color is that in this
blended region um between where it's black and
where it's bleached it tends to go a bit brassy
and it's a lot easier to hide that brassiness if
you have a warm hair color so a lot of the time
when my hair is this cool purple it'll start
off the first day after i wash it looking really
good and then after a while it just starts looking
a bit like brown and because the brown doesn't
really work with cool it mostly just looks dirty
so this time really i'm going for that purplish
pink color and i'm not really trying to get it all
the one color so last time i tried to always just
have my hair all one color but this time i'm kind
of okay with it being slightly different colors
everywhere i think it's partly just because i'm
indecisive about whether i want pink or purple
the ends of my hair are a little bit stained
from my old die and so it's a bit brassier it's a
bit hard to see on this camera i think but it's a
bit brassier than the rest of my hair so i think
this sort of mixed color is working quite well
for me and it's also a lot lower maintenance so
again i do all of my hair coloring in the shower
nothing stays on my hair for more than like
three minutes because i'm pretty impatient
last time i used to always dye my hair once every
two or three weeks and that's just too much effort
for me now so everything is just colored shampoos
and conditioners with colored conditioner i mix
it myself i put my dye in a lush tub and blend it
out with uberliss hydrating conditioner i got this
ages ago and i don't know why i don't really use
it on my hair as conditioner i just always end up
mixing it probably because it doesn't have much
amodimethicone the dye i've been using is the
brand especially plus this is really good because
it's like a three minute hair dye unfortunately
i can't find this on ebay anymore or anywhere
really so if you have another good suggestion for
a three minute hair dye i am really really keen on
that in the shower i always use a crocodile clip
these just hold a massive amount of hair this one
is from a brand called cricket i picked it up at
a hair convention in the before times it has these
ribbed or dotty grips which means that it's really
easy to hold on to in the shower so this can hold
like all of my hair and i have quite a lot of hair
yeah so it holds it all it holds a lot
of it even like when it's doubled up
on top of my hair um yeah so it has this cool
mechanism where you can hold large amounts
and it'll still grip really hard another
amazing product that i've recently found
is the igk mixed feelings leave-in blonde toning
drops this is a really intense purple product that
has the same purple dye as purple shampoos you
can mix this into anything i mix it a lot into
my garnier leave-in conditioning mix i mix it into
my dye if you do get this just to let you know you
press the bottom of the tube to get the drops
out you don't just like shake it like this and
hope that something comes out so don't do what i
did for 15 minutes sometimes if i do see a bit of
brassiness here i'll just put a couple of drops
on my hands rub them together to spread it and
then just do this very quickly and then wash
my hands immediately to stop it from staining
and that works really well as well for drying my
hair i'm still using the aquis towels that i got
years ago these are microfiber towels that are
designed to dry your hair really really quickly
so when your hair is wet it's at its most fragile
and so you just want to blot it dry as much as you
can i really like how light these are so if you
wrap it up in a turban on your head it doesn't
hurt your neck it doesn't fall all over the place
with hair dryers i'm still using the panasonic one
this has that nano e stuff in the top and so i
found that it dries my hair out a lot less than
the dyson which i was also using before this has
a really good mode which is the scalp mode this
gets it to like the perfect temperature to blast
the top of your hair without burning your scalp
i have found that in this new working from home
life i've been washing my hair earlier in the day
so that way i don't have to dry my hair as much
at night so if my hair's still damp like an hour
before i go to bed i just give it a quick whiz
for brushing my hair i'm still using the tangle
teezers i find these really good for getting
through your hair without too much tugging so even
if you put it up the top and then if you get to
a stuck bit like don't tear it through just like
gently apply pressure and it will detangle itself
so you don't have to like do that whole thing i've
been using silk pillow cases almost exclusively
now i found that silk is just really nice on my
hair especially because it's so easily damaged now
i've been using these ones from lilysilk they're
good they're cheap but they are a bit thin so they
might not last as long as something that's thicker
i have one from shhh silk which has lasted ages
also this is a tool i got off ebay it's meant to
be like a shower scalp scrubber i haven't really
worked out how to use it i can't really tell if i
like it or not i think you just shampoo your hair
and just put it on there and try to do that but i
do feel like it is tugging a bit on my hair which
i'm not sure is the best for it while it's wet
so if you've ever used one of these and you can
give me some tips or tell me what your experiences
were let me know in the comments with hair ties
i usually do wear my hair in a ponytail i've been
using these thick hair ties that i got off ebay
i'm pretty sure they were like ten dollars for
a hundred or something but these are really good
because they don't have an end so there's no rough
snaggy bit that gets caught on your hair the cats
have been stealing these so every couple of years
i just have to buy 200 and that usually lasts me
i think i straight up forgot to talk about this
last time but i also have this shaver so i have an
undercut because my hair i just got too much hair
so i'll see if i can show you oh there it is so
yeah i just have too much hair so i found that
cutting that has made my hair a lot thinner a lot
lighter and it dries a lot more quickly so you can
probably see how messy the undercut is and that's
because i'd shave it myself every once in a while
i try to get someone to help me shave it but
usually it's just me in the shower i bend over
and i use this this is a remington shaver and i
pretty much just grope to where the edge of my
hair is and then i move in a little bit and just
shave so yeah the edges are a bit gross because i
don't want to cut off too much of the long
hair accidentally so i'd rather cut off less
than too much but yeah it's surprisingly easy
to do it myself um you just have to like feel
it and then aim it this is really nice and safe
it doesn't cut you or anything it just cuts hair
so you can just like do a lot of groping without
any sort of danger so i hope this video was
useful let me know if you've used any of these
products before or if you have any recommendations
especially with a quick hair dye also with
pink shampoo if you liked it you can give it a
thumbs up and subscribe you can also follow me on
instagram at lab muffin beauty science and check
out my blog if you like more of the science behind
beauty products see you next time to nerd out more